Vanda bucks is the movement that removes
the box asking about a person's
conviction history so when a person is
applying for a job now it's typical for
there to be a box that says have you
ever been convicted of a felony well
there's been a movement to you rather
keep that box to eliminate that box and
we're not asking to overall completely
not ask that question what staying put
it later on in the process once the
person has been found eligible and
qualified before they offer them the job
they could inquire about that and then a
person has a right to be able to explain
the challenge is when you submit an
application or you are asked in any
intervention interview about any
conviction history then what that
normally triggers behind the stigma
associated behind fear that the person
if they're not trained they're gonna
discriminate that applications may not
make it past that big so the first time
you went to prison you were only 19
years old what was going on in your life
at that time and how how were those
factors similar for not just yourself
but other young men of color
growing up here in America many of us
broke with lots of hate and that means
it we internalized a lot of the violence
we see on TV in the communities and at
home and so for many of us it was going
up and having to deal with that rage
what do we do with that rates most of
time it was trying to find ways to do it
and the systems of oppression the races
the we experienced actress in school
that not being able to speak proper
English initially that's the lift issue
I had growing up force many of us to
support each other and we've been doing
so without a critical consciousness
forces to getting what they call
to reality the condition that we live
under forces many of us to live in the
inform economy in poor market that makes
us do crimes we don't have to do
are you comfortable saying with that
crime list unnecessarily I rather those
focus on the message that I have and
while she be focused on the path where
the whole character is not measured by
one axe and a few actors rather by the
overall character somebody might say
that there are you know frequent
incidences of people exiting prison and
then committing a crime and going right
back to prison so from the employers
perspective why should they take that
risk so the question that we normally
ask both people when is enough enough
you know if we got sentence at nineteen
like in might get 20 years old and I'm
36 now why should I be sent in 16 later
be on the same sentence of not being
able to sustain my family and then
before to live off the inform economy
that comes with all the Manatee here on
the news and there should always be a
nexus between the job responsibilities
and the actual conviction so if I are
convicted of DUI back in 96 and all of a
sudden applying now in 2015 for a job
that doesn't require any driving depth
convictions not be used to judge me in a
pin minute job if I have all the
qualifications with other lesser lawmen
to work there
to get a sense of how prison happy
Americans are consider that in Germany
only six percent of people convicted get
locked up compare that to